bref quand j'ai voulu préparer
l'émission je me suis dit qu'il fallait
que j'appelle tous les artistes qui ont
fait canal+ ces trente dernières années
j'ai appelé franck gastambide il me dit
j'ai appelé manu payet qui m'a dit j'ai
appelé jpa d'imedi pendant deux shih qui
avait une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne c'est qu'ils avaient une super
carrière pas se laisser dépasser par
canal la mauvaise et qu'il pouvait pas
passer dans mon émission sur canal parce
qu'ils avaient une supérieure à ce qui
s'était passé par canal j'appelais jamel
il a rien dit mais c'est parce qu'il n'a
pas répondu
il m'a envoyé un texto avec marc est
désolé antoine j'ai pas pu te répondre
parce que j'ai une super carrière parce
que j'ai passés par canal
il m'a proposé faire une vision à 15
heures j'ai dit ok j'ai appelé
quinquennat il m'a dit écoute à
conditions j'ai appelé benjamin lavernhe
il m'a dit j'ai appelé josé garcia il me
dit oui d'accord
oui oui bien sûr rappel le problème
c'est que j'étais là il était 15 heures
j'ai essayé de joindre jamel j'ai
attendu longtemps très longtemps
à 18 ans je me suis dit qu'il était
peut-être pas en france et je n'étais
pas sûr même fuseau horaire que kamel à
21h je me suis rappelé que la terre
entière n'était pas sur le même fuseau
horaire que jamel heureusement il y
avait encore plein de gens qui étaient
passés par canal et qui étaient encore
disponibles
l'émission commencé on a vu fred
encodage camille caudin pas en kaunas
bertrand jusqu'à enchanteur carine et
myriam sofiane sofianh bérengère a eu la
migraine aux malades plus à berkane a
dit ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir et
aurier avec un chat et s'appelle entre
temps j'avais toujours pas de nouvelles
de djamel démission était finie elle
était marrante même pendant le tournage
antoine
c'était marrant les chiens aussi été
marrant et puis toi même et tu arrives
ici commence quand l'émission génies en
fait on vient de terminer il m'a regardé
j'ai regardé il m'a regardé j'ai regardé
il me dit qu'il avait traversé tous
marre j'ai traversé tous panama henry
bus à furiani
il a redit que moi faire un petit fou
n'importe quoi la main depuis sorti un
papier je suis pas faire ça il a dit et
cette réplique je lui dis il a dit bref
on a fait replay ben voilà bref on a
fait replay quelques affaires en vidéo
les techniciens des caméras on nous
impose de minutes ils sont encore là les
mecs tu peux faire n'importe quel sketch
je peux pas je peux pas djamel j'ai
inscrits sur l'écologie toi voilà
qu'arrive sur son petit poids assez bien
cette fois joué un petit point les gens
il y moins de surprises et met déjà dans
un petit pot voix en costume de carottes
physiquement des granges type e c'est
possible que lui que les gens rigolent
tu vois je veux pas tout de suite
en revanche on va faire la suite de
replay ça va s'appeler l'ireep les
replays oui le petit poêle et au tout ça
oui mais quoi été tuées et 85 ans
bientôt
[Musique]